aber jetzt auch ganz viele leute ich
gehe es jedoch einer sparkasse
leverkusen kommt sie ihren weil das von
erich zufolge ist kann er wie komische
auf einmal so viele ankam
erst mal abgesetzt also leute das kann
man eigentlich das bin ich eigentlich
nicht wahrhaben das kann nicht sein
ein 25-jähriger kann doch nicht sein
dass er sich zu einem treffen mit einer
angeblich 16 jährigen locken lässt
herzlich willkommen zum neuen video
leute von dem ich gesagt nicht gedacht
hätte dass ich es machen würde weil das
thema was ihr auch einfach eine sehr
vernünftige gesehen habt 1 ist von dem
ich dachte dass es auf einem kanal
abgehakt wäre nämlich die frank busemann
kanadischen länger verfolgt wisst ihr
dass ich das eine oder andere video über
die projekt gemacht habe mich schon als
darüber lustig gemacht habe wie bereist
sie ihre videos fähigen und wie sehr sie
hat auf alles zu scheißen entscheiden
was irgendwie so normalen youtube
ausmacht und ja ich hab irgendwann so
entschieden für mein eigenes geistiges
wohl dass ich die sache einfach abhaken
weil es war so ein bisschen so ein kampf
gegen windmühlen versteht weil sie
meinen also wächst hat darüber ab und
man macht sich darüber lustig dass man
tauscht sich dabei wird sich zu machen
aber es ändert sich halt einfach nichts
deswegen habe die sache einfach abgehakt
irgendwann aber heute ist eine sache
passiert die die ganze geschichte mit
dem cross ein bisschen anderes licht
rückt und zwar haben sich heute zwei der
größten youtuber in deutschland
namentlich und monte dafür entschieden
eine ansage an die post zu machen und
das wiederum ist für mich anlass mal die
ganze antipathie die ich für die pros
mal übrig hatte wieder auszugraben und
deren anzeige video und die
anschuldigung die hinter dem man seine
videos stehen zu analysieren fangen wir
mit dem ersten kritikpunkt jungen leute
machen nämlich dass die post auf sogar
auf ihre eigenen zuschauer chancen aber
ja smr auch definitiv also klasse kanal
und ich denke das reflektiert wieder
ganz gut hier zu hören für ein community
steht nämlich gar nicht dazu muss ich
eine sache erklären heute und zwar ist
die sache die bei dem kongress dass sie
hier normalen kanal haben nämlich krank
braucht also press tv oder machen sie so
videos drauf wie 10.000 euro aufbessert
ist 100 euro urlaub 70.000 euro
diamanten
er ist out gekauft rufen niemals
vorgeben drei uhr nachts auf facetime
man das natürlich ein video was mir
persönlich sehr zusagt das ist und er
konnte diese richtung gehenden auf dem
kanal sieht man auch schon also der
kommt zwei millionen abonnenten und dann
halt so einfach mails zu machen wie hier
jetzt bei dem video eine nacht in
gruseligsten hotel deutschland also ich
habe noch nie einen kanal mit zwei
millionen abonnenten gesehen der seine
farm nails sohin scheiße also ich habe
einfach das bild von sich genommen und
so gestaucht sie komplett müll aus aber
okay und da haben sie doch ihren zwei
kanariengelben kanal der oder früher
geben kann als früher ich weiß nicht
gameboys oder gaming groß weil sie nicht
ganz genau
er hatte aber auf jeden fall das weiß
nämlich dahin geschaut habe über eine
million abonnenten ja erst haben sie die
abonnenten versteckt und machen jetzt
sma auf dem kanal
na ja und das ist der erste kritikpunkt
der auch so gut die einstellung der pram
post zeigt sie bauen sich hat der gaming
community auf und ja dann denken sich
moment mal vielleicht können wir mit sma
mehr geld machen und scheißen erstmal
komplett auf alles und wechseln so
hardcore von deutschen gaming kanal auf
englischen elster kanal englische titel
englische sun blade einfach mal
gewechselt
deutsches gaming zu englischem sma und
sehr treue gaming community aufzubauen
und dann die anzuspucken indem man
einfach den kanal umbenennt mm groß und
punktekonto zu wahren es ist auf jeden
fall schon mal ein kluger schachzug man
muss dazu sagen natürlich hat immer noch
jeder youtuber selber die freiheit zu
entscheiden was er auf seinem eigenen
kanal macht und dass auch was ich in
diesem video machen möchte als ich
möchte aufhält bisschen die kritik von
monza manchen stellen relativieren wo
sie vielleicht wissen übers ziel
hinausschießt aber zwischen den content
machen die man selbst machen möchte und
deswegen war sein konzert umstellt und
ja von deutschen gaming content auf
englisch ja erstmal videos zu wechseln
ist auf jeden fall auch nice gegenüber
den zuschauern die wirklich super haben
im bereich von gaming und sich immer
gefreut haben und den kanal macht
einfach platz und denkt dann so kann der
nächste hype ist gut das ist eine sache
die ich schon 80.000 mal gesagt habe in
meinen videos ich versuche immer mich
nicht nur lustig zu machen sondern auch
bisschen zu analysieren gewissen
mehrwert mir zu geben es kommt einfach
extrem castor überall
willy brandt kurs selbst im video sich
so verhalten als würden sie komplett
darauf scheißen was ihre zuschauer so
denken weil sie wahrscheinlich hätte ich
genau wissen dass ihre eigenen zuschauer
extrem jungen sind und denen einfach
alles abkaufen und das nutzen sie
einfach aus und in den letzten video
haben die post gesagt ja wenn ihr euch
jetzt sich angucken wollt dann geht doch
einfach von dem kanal weg oder er hört
auf zu denken da frage ich mich wie kann
man denn eigentlich so wenig raffen im
leben das natürlich 1 boss muss man baut
sich wahrscheinlich jahre hinweg gaming
kanal auf der über eine million
abonnenten etwas schon krass also und
wird über jahre alt gelten hoch auf
einmal wechselt man so radikal auf sma
ja wie ihr wollt weiter gaming content
sehen was ist los
das ist natürlich längst nicht der
einzige anklagepunkt leute der nächste
anlaufpunkt ist der name
zwar haben die project fonds ihren
gaming canaria sma bloß umbenannt der
haken ist nur es gibt in deutschland
noch einen anderen kanal der auch sma
büros heißt von irgendwie zwei kids
betrieben wird führt auf dem
sahnehäubchen ist einfach dass euch
wirklich alles scheißegal ist ja vor
einem ort angefangen hier mit dem kanal
und es gibt einfach schon einen
deutschen asm airbus kanal ja leute auch
das passt einfach ins bild und ich sag
das nicht damit ihr euch zu hause denkt
ja ok
es passt ins bild dass heißt dass es
okay ist nein aber es schaut mich
einfach nicht so ich genau so schätze
ich die presse ein solange sie das
gefühl haben sie können mit irgendwas
davon kommen
machen sie es einfach wird ist es
relativ egal wie andere leute sich dabei
für welchen effekt das möglicherweise
auf ihre eigenen zuschauer hat so
komplett wurscht und zwar von den beiden
jungs hier die haben schon seit sieben
monaten also viel viel länger ist euer
kanal überhaupt existiert machen die
hier ihren arzt mehr bloß kanal und das
wusstet ihr auch ganz genau also diese
erstmal büros mit 20.000 abonnenten hat
in den kanal schon deutlich länger und
hatte an diesem 7 an dieser stelle was
was war es nämlich wenn man sich neuen
kanal macht auf youtube checkt man
natürlich erstmal auf allen plattformen
okay ist ja schon vergeben wenn ich den
namen mehr zunehme kriege ich dir welche
probleme weil andere kanäle ähnlich
heißen und dann werden die er gefunden
wenn leute über mich suchen das wird
natürlich vermeiden als youtuber
dementsprechend check jeder gibt es den
namen schon die freezers mit sicherheit
auch gemacht haben mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit den kanal von diesen
zwei duos gesehen
dann haben sie gedacht
scheiß auf die finden uns erst mal
genauso wir den größeren kanal und das
waren vorher dias mehr bloß ihr habt den
eib den kids ihr habt diesen kids
einfach den kanal namen geklaut oder
einfach kopiert ja der mofcom von zwei
jungs die dafür bekannt sind dass sie
einfach ja einfach regelmäßig videos
faken manchmal schlecht fällt manchmal
gut faken aber so die motivation ist
immer so dass gleiche dem konkurs geht
es nur um das endprodukt den geht es
wahrscheinlich um das geld was sie
daraus ziehen und wie sehr dieses ziel
kommen dass wir am ende so die summe auf
ihrem konto stimmt ist dann glaube ich
relativ egal deswegen macht es auch für
sie keinen unterschied ob sie ein video
wirklich authentisch von anfang bis ende
drehen oder ob sie einfach faken weil
sich denken okay was ist uns wichtig so
unsere zuschauer sind acht die glaube
ist uns so oder so egal ob es fake oder
echt machen dann fällt es halt so und
jetzt kommen wir zu dem süßesten thema
in diesem video und einem thema was mich
persönlich auch geschockt hat ich hatte
damit hätte ich wirklich nicht gerechnet
hatte schon vor gefällt das bild von
frankfurt aus meinem bisherigen videos
aber das hat mir schon geschockt und
zwar das tatsächlich irgendein kleiner
youtuber namens ayew calvin von den
trendbruch erfolgreich gekämpft hat also
hat ihn gebetet geködert quasi hat sich
als 16-jähriges mädchen ausgeschrieben
oder tatsächlich calvin der achtung laut
youtube wiki am 20.06 1940 geboren ist
das heißt es am heutigen tage 25 jahre
alt ja erst geschafft einen 25-jährigen
dazu zu bringen sich mit einer
16-jährigen zu treffen war schon mal ein
fake für uns gemacht leute und schwöre
auf alles so der account von 0 80
beiträge ich habe null leute abonniert
immerhin eine beschreibung stand 16
jahre hat er das ist so das problem an
dieser ganzen sache also es ist noch mal
ein anderes paar schuhe wenn man wenn
der person schreibt die vielleicht ein
bisschen reifer aussieht oder so und man
hat vielleicht nie explizit nachgefragt
auch immer das machen sollte
das kann den schuldigen dafür aber wenn
man das nicht gemacht hat weil man grund
genug hatte an zu dem was die person
volljährig ist oder whatever
dann ist eine sache aber wenn man als 25
jähriger mit einem install count
schreibt indessen bei 16 jahre alt steht
und dann zum treffen aushandelt
[Musik]
3 was willst du mit der willst du denn
in der schule helfen
sag mir bitte nicht das was mit dir
anfangen will ist neun jahre jünger als
du okay auf jeden fall leute habe ich
dann gemacht habe schon angeschrieben
sondern habe ich gespielt und dann
müssen wir uns gedulden und
zurückhaltend in die wanne also man muss
an der schnell aussagen respekt dafür
dass du das gemacht hast was und an
calvin positiv gemeinte ratschlag für
die zukunft einerseits das video was wir
jetzt hier gerade schauen deutet eine
sehr eindeutige richtung die kein gutes
licht auf dem schein lässt solltest du
wirklich bist dato mit sollten dem alter
getroffen haben stapel so ist einfach zu
jung es ist gerade noch legal in
deutschland gerade so wer die person 15
statt 16 würde die sache schon ein
bisschen anders aussehen aber so oder so
den hinweis der nicht gerne calvin da
geben würde ist kollege bei irgend was
wir auch belegen bissig wird überall so
du hast zwei million abonnenten auf
youtube 300.000 verlauf sogar rechne
damit dass leute die verarschen wollen
okay ein bisschen mehr misstrauen ist
angebracht weil er glaubt einfach so
diesem account ohne bild so ja ok
kristen hat kein bild drin aber es ist
16 16 25 die gelegenheit kann ich nicht
erwarten lassen so jetzt bis dato katar
mein okay okay geht ja ist fake ich mein
sohn jett kann jeder felgen kein problem
doch problem weil dieser jupa
videoaufnahmen von calvin wir zum
treffen kommt
[Musik]
ja da ist wird es dann langsam da wird
so langsam wirklich mies und
kompromittierend leute weil ich habe ja
auch ein video auf in dem punkt dass man
reagiert nur die auch im auto
herumfahren und das war auf jeden fall
ein amg c-klasse meine ich das ist ein
amg c klasse coupé so wie es aussieht
der typ sieht aus wie calvin so das
deutet alles schon eine gewisse richtung
alles gibt aber noch mehr beweise
nämlich hat jetzt sogar sprachaufnahmen
von calvin einer sparkasse leverkusen
kommt es vermehrt zu voll ist kann auch
komisch dass auf einmal so viele ankam
habe ich das mal abgesetzt
also leute das kann man eigentlich das
will ich eigentlich nicht wahrhaben
das kann nicht sein ein 25-jähriger der
irgendwie auch schon erfolgreich auf
video womit auch immer so der muss ja
etwas im kopf haben kann doch nicht sein
dass er sich zu einem treffen mit einer
angeblich 16 jährigen locken lässt aber
ja leute um zusammenzufassen hoffe ich
dass dieses video jetzt auf einem kanal
und auch das bei uns nochmal bis ein
anderes licht auf ein paar mehr leute so
ein bisschen hinter die kulissen blicken
lasse ich will aber auch zeitlich sagen
das ist nicht mein ziel irgendwelche
leute fertig zu machen oder
runterzuziehen dauert einfach so ich
habe keinen spaß am leid anderer
menschen dementsprechend hoffe ich dass
die post den aktuellen aufschreis den
warnschuss wahrnehmen den sie dringend
gebraucht haben und endlich mal was
ändern aber ob das tatsächlich passieren
wird heute das werden erst die nächsten
tage und wochen zeigen ich habe mich
wohl hier und schon mal in folge stellt
das video verlinkt hier oben könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren will in dieses
wie unterhaltsam findet das was als
augen und macht's gut